absurde c'est ainsi que markus wolf a
qualifié aujourd'hui son procès cet
homme de 70 ans qui a dirigé
l'espionnage de l'allemagne de l'est de
1953 à 86 et qui a inspiré entre
parenthèses l'écrivain john le carré est
poursuivi pour trahison et corruption
markus wolf s'étonne de voir la justice
d'une allemagne désormais réunifié faire
une sorte de tri entre les bons espions
de l'ouest et les mauvais de l'est
commentaire de notre correspondant
pascal guimier un petit air de festival
de cannes au tribunal de düsseldorf
l'acteur a beau avoir déjà beaucoup
donné c'est encore une star
markus wolf 70 ans profession
fonctionnaire à la retraite mais
derrière l'image rassurante
cachée derrière des lunettes noires un
autre markus wolf alias l'homme sans
visage alias l'espion venu du froid
alias le beau michard pour les dames
car pendant plus de trente ans de bons
et loyaux services secrets wolf a dirigé
de main de maître l'espionnage
est-allemand doctoresse manipulation
spécialiste de l'infiltration ils
étaient les yeux et les oreilles de la
rdr kunter guillaume colonel de la stasi
conseiller et confident du chancelier
brandt un coup de marquise vol gabriel
gast directrice des renseignements ouest
allemand passé de l'autre côté est
devenue espionne par amour
encore un succès de marques ea sports au
total 5 à 6 ans taupe à des postes
stratégiques
certaines peut être encore en activité
alors aujourd'hui l'allemagne accuse le
maître espion de haute trahison un
procès politique rétorque paul un procès
illégal arguments seuls les agents de
l'est sont poursuivis et condamnés
quand leurs collègues occidentaux coule
des jours tranquilles résultat deux
poids deux mesures la cour
constitutionnelle devra trancher
alors la justice de l'allemagne unifiée
continue de faire piètre figure procès
honecker annulé procès mille que enlisé
procès modrow plutôt mal engagé
aujourd'hui on demande des comptes alors
qu'ils wolf sans savoir si la procédure
pour aller jusqu'à son terme normal